over the past few years we've learned a
lot about cyberpunk 2077 s world it's
look and some of the characters but what
exactly is the plot of the game well
thanks to some hands-on time with the
first few hours and a lot of info from
CD Projekt RED we now have a clear
picture of these journey and night city
at least for the prologue if you want to
go into cyberpunk 2077 as spoiler free
as possible then this video is not for
you if you are more interested in what
the gameplay is like you can check out
our breakdown of exactly how cyberpunks
gameplay systems work tonight city and
the afterlife let's start at the very
beginning when you first create your
character he has three different
backstories for you to choose from each
one starts the game with a completely
unique intro that takes place in
distinct locations in and outside of
night city if you've played the Bioware
RPG Dragon Age Origins that would be a
good point of comparison for what to
expect the street kid intro takes place
in the underworld of haywood a
relatively wealthy district of night
city but by no means a safe neighborhood
v starts off at el coyote coho a local
dive bar they frequent where they take a
carjacking job for a fixer named Kirk as
expected
the job ends up going rather south
you're under arrest
that's what I can see them nice and slow
[Music]
[Applause]
the second backstory is the Nomad V is a
lone drifter making their way through a
small town out in the Badlands the
Badlands are the outskirts of night city
it's a barren wasteland due to pollution
and its many oil fields Nomad V is
simply passing through on their way to
night city but ends up running into
trouble with a local sheriff as well as
corporate agents while crossing the
border
[Music]
you are transporting contraband that is
corporate property [ __ ] your problem
psycho sooo this looked like a landing
pad too you could have [ __ ] crushed
us looking for no beef with you finally
there's the corporate backstory
corporate v starts off in arasaka tower
as an agent working for their boss
Jenkins V gets roped into Jenkins
attempt to a corporate coup which lands
them in hot water all three of these
backstories have lasting consequences on
V's personality with unique dialogue
options as well as story and character
ramifications down the line it's in each
of these backstories where V will meet
and befriend Jackie wells with their
relationship differing in each one
corporate V is already friends with
Jackie Nomad V meets them on a job in
the Badlands and street kid V runs into
them on the carjacking job not their
personal goal pod just biz after the
intro the game moves into the prologue
regardless of your chosen backstory V
and Jackie are now making a life in
Watson a district of night city filled
with low-income housing and industrial
factories looking to make it big as a
couple of hotshot cyberpunks the to
start working with Dexter DeSean this
leads into the story quest the pickup
which was the gameplay video shown way
back in 2018 where V and Jackie needed
to buy stolen military from the
Maelstrom gang two questions what the
[ __ ] going on and who the [ __ ] is this
and that right there is a solid look at
how cyberpunk 2077 opens with its first
few hours so what's the goal for the
rest of the game apparently it's all
about finding a rare prototype that
holds the secret to immortality this is
where we're gonna start putting some
pieces together based on the info we
know we are gonna get a bit speculative
here so don't take what I'm saying as
gospel because I'm probably gonna get
some details wrong okay so the pickup
quest line is a test from Dexter to Sean
to see if Jackie and V are reliable and
trustworthy enough to keep on his big
job
scanning the serious job just now
playing God gives you and compared us
smashing of us careful you exist
thanks to our hands-on with the game as
well as the newest trailer we now know
that the job is to steal a piece of
Arisaka prototype tech known as the
relic there's this prototype tech a
biochip to be precise jobs to grab
esident belongs to a forester in the e3
2019 trailer we saw the aftermath of a
job pulled off by V and Jackie where
they stole a chip they pulled way more
heat than they had anticipated resulting
in Jackie's death and as Shaun being
pissed off he double-crossed V shooting
them and tossing their body into a
landfill v wakes up in the landfill to
see the digital ghost of legendary
rocker boy Johnny silver hand wake the
[ __ ] up samurai we have a city to burn
we know a fair amount about Johnny
thanks to the cyberpunk 2020 rulebook
and some of its supplementary materials
Johnny supposedly died over fifty years
ago during the fourth corporate war
while trying to rescue his girlfriend
alt Cunningham she had been kidnapped by
arasaka and forced to create a program
called the soul killer which creates a
digital copy of someone's mind the exact
nature of Johnny's death has always been
shrouded in mystery with some believing
him to still be alive if we take all
this information we've been given so far
and start piecing it together we get a
pretty clear picture the relic Dexter
deshaun hires V and Jackie to steal is
likely the rare prototype that holds the
key to immortality the relic belongs to
arasaka and as its name suggests it's
probably a very old piece of tech this
fits the bill perfectly for the soul
killer program which by digitizing
someone's mind does indeed create a form
of immortality
Johnny silver Han disappeared in arasaka
all those years ago back when his
girlfriend created Soul killer it's
likely Johnny ended up using the soul
killer program which explains how he can
still exist in 2077 as a digital ghost
and at some point
ended up in v's head during the heist
assuming we got all of that right that's
a hell of a setup we see snippets of the
heist as well as Dex's betrayal of V in
the recently released trailer and see
Projekt RED has said that everything
shown in it is from the game's prologue
of course that still leaves the whole
rest of the game's plot to be discovered
when we finally play cyberpunk 2077
later this year regardless there is a
lot more cyberpunk information that has
been revealed if you want a huge
breakdown of how the game actually plays
from character progression to side
quests then go check out our video
detailing all that we also got hands on
with all three of the games intros so if
you want more details and impressions go
check that out as well finally
GameSpot's Jake Decker into more Huseyin
will be hosting a Q&A they'll answer
your burning questions so go hit them up
on Twitter or leave your question in the
comments below and of course thanks for
watching all the way to the end of this
video if you enjoyed it keep an eye on
this channel for even more videos on
cyberpunk 2077
[Music]